there is no more ridiculed literary
genre than the self-help book
intellectually minded people universally
scorned the idea of them self-help books
don't appear on reading lists at any
prestigious university they're not
reviewed by highbrow journals and it's
inconceivable that a major literary
prize could ever be awarded to one of
their authors this concerted attack on
the entire genre of self-help is a
symptom of a romantic prejudice against
the idea of emotional education offering
explicit emotional education is regarded
as beneath the dignity of any serious
writer we should if we are at all
intelligent just know how to live
already unsurprisingly therefore the
quality of all self-help books is at
present highly degraded the most
accomplished stylists and sharpest
thinkers would feel ashamed to put their
name to a work which would be destined
to end up on the most ludicrous shelves
of any bookshop yet not all eras have
shared this dismissive attitude towards
self-help in the classical culture of
ancient Greece and Rome it was taken for
granted that the highest ambition of any
author was to offer the reader an
emotional education that could guide
them towards fulfilment self-help books
with a pinnacle of literature the most
admired thinkers Plato Aristotle Cicero
Seneca Plutarch and Marcus Aurelius all
wrote self-help books whose aim was to
teach us to live and die well
furthermore they deployed every resource
of intelligence wit and style in writing
their manuals so as to ensure that their
messages would delight the intellectual
as well as the emotional faculties
Senecas on anger and Marcus Aurelius
meditations are among the greatest works
of literature of any nation in any era
they are also undeniably self-help books
it can look as if humans stopped writing
good self-help are
a fall of Rome but once we view culture
as a tool for emotional education many
more works emerge as in fact belonging
to the currently much-maligned jar of
self-help for example Tolstoy's war and
peace explicitly aims to teach
compassion calm and forgiveness it
offers guidance around money
manners relationships and career
development it seeks to show us how to
be a good friend and how to be a better
parent it clearly is a self-help book it
just doesn't happen to be officially
described this way by the current
guardians of culture Marcel Proust in
search of lost time is similarly also a
self-help book teaching us how to
surrender our attachment to romantic
love and social status in favor of a
focus on art and thought it's not an
insult to describe such masterpieces as
self-help books it's a way of correctly
identifying their ambitions which are to
guide us away from folly and move us
towards more sincere and authentic ways
of living such works show us that
self-help shouldn't be a low-grade
marginal undertaking the desire to guide
and teach wisdom should be at the core
of all ambitious writing in the
bookstores of the Utopia the self-help
shelves would be the most prestigious of
them all and on them would sit many of
the most distinguished works of world
literature returned at last to their
true home
if you liked this film please subscribe
to our channel and click the Bell icon
to turn on notifications
you